I'm volunteering at a cat sanctuary
on an island in Greece
I just arrived a few days ago
and it's honestly been such a dream
there are almost 60 cats at the sanctuary
and they are all so so cute
this is Margarita
she's the only kitten
and she's a crazy little thing
work for about four hours in the morning
and then we have breakfast together
which is always so delish
the property we're on is so beautiful
and the island is stunning
I can't wait to explore it
so we're literally like a five minute walk to the beach
so my first day I decided to go check out the beach
and I was just blown away
all the White Houses are so pretty as well
this is so beautiful
I cannot believe I'm gonna be here for like two months
I'm so happy right now
this is like the best decision I've ever made